okay i hate these videos that go into a
million different things
and wait forever to get to the point so
let's get to the point nfts
oh what are they a non-fungible token
is basically something that's unique
that can't be
duplicated as a digital asset
for instance okay explain amanda you got
this so
ethereum that is a cryptocurrency
similar to
bitcoin or bmv one of my favs or
dogecoin which a lot of people know
about those are all
fungible you can change one ethereum for
another and you're gonna have the same
thing an
nft is different from a cryptocurrency
such as
ethereum because there's a little bit
more to what's being recorded
about the nft i guess the best way to
think about it is
if you're buying an nft it's similar to
buying
something that's non-fungible like
a trading card if you're buying one
trading card and changing it for another
trading card they're not going to be the
same they're always going to be
different from one another and they're
never going to be
duplicates and if they are they're still
going to have unique qualities to them
that make them a little bit different
same same but different all right moving
on
with that over complicated explanation i
hope
you're with me my brain tends to jump
around
on all these topics but let me get to it
okay with nfts they can be anything
that's digital it could be
a picture of a tweet a gift a gif a gif
it could be a music it could be anything
you want it to be
anything that you want to sell and
people are willing to buy
could be an nft as long as it's digital
so most
nfts are on the ethereum
blockchain one of my favorite nfts is
the crypto punks i do own one
crypto punk i wish i owned more but that
was one of my first
nft purchases i mainly did it because
there's only
10 000 ever made and that number cannot
be changed because once it was launched
it was
locked and loaded and that's how many
there are and it was launched as an
experiment to the idea of adding value
to non-fungible tokens to digital art
and then it picked up and the two guys
that launched it
forget their names i'll put them here
they kept a thousand for themselves gave
away the rest for free
ethereum blockchain is what they
launched it on now other
cryptocurrencies can have their own
blockchains
and launch their own nfts but the
majority of nfts are traded within the
ethereum
blockchain it makes it a lot easier to
trade
and you can buy with ethereum and just
keep it in your wallets and store it in
your wallets usually they are digital
wallets but there are hard wallets as
well
that you can put your coins and tokens
on
and just keep in your safe or deep down
in your basement but hopefully it
doesn't flood because there's only one
copy of that and with digital wallets
you do not want to give out or
ever lose your seed phrase and people
are afraid of those being hacked
really really difficult to be hacked
anyways so they launched crypto punks
people picked it up started exchanging
trading them
for different amounts setting them for
sale for this much ethereum and
like room growing grew so proof of
concept
was shown and it's still growing today
as
one of the first nfts to launch and i
bought myself my very own
crypto punk she's a beauty they're great
because they all have unique
qualities which allows them to have
different amounts of rarity
hence the different price points and
even after
i got mine i think it was just a few
weeks later i had a bid on it for forty
thousand dollars more
from when i bought it and i think if i
can remember correctly i bought it for
around 70 something thousand
because i saw the value and then it
already increased that much
right after i bought it i didn't sell
because i know she's gonna go
to the moon i know they look like very
simple
pixel art it's just the concept of it
and
the rarity of it and the idea of it
being one of the first brings so much
value already and we all know that
in life in general if you're not first
you're like
but that's not true in this case it's
still early to get involved in nfts and
cryptocurrency in general it tends to be
a volatile market because it is still so
new and the way it just works and for me
i love the volatility of it it excites
me some people cannot handle that
you shouldn't go into it and this is not
financial advice but i think you
shouldn't go into it
unless you have some disposable income
that you can work and play around with
i love it i believe in it so that's who
you're hearing from right now
all right moving on nfts can be fine all
right even christie's has auctioned off
different nfts
even with people i think his nft went
for around
over 69 million it was the first 5
000 days or something i really need to
write notes on these things but i'm
going out of here
for over 69 million doll hairs and it
was a combination of
different digital art that he made over
5000 days and the thing is and what's
super
important to know with nfts and keep in
mind that the artist
can keep the copyright and the um
what's it called reproduction rights so
artists can keep both of those and they
can continue to sell
duplicate posts different styles of nfts
that they have sold to you
already and the person that bought the
nft gets the basic usage rights or
it depends on what the agreement and the
contract is so it's good to keep that in
mind so if you see an artist post
something with similar imagery
for example people took one of the
images
in the 5 000 images digital art piece
that he auctioned off for 69 million
and sold that image separately so with
that in mind he was completely in his
own rights because that's what the
agreement was with the christie's
auction piece of
the 5000 digital art piece with that
whoever bought that
so you may be wondering well what's the
point of buying an nft then where's the
value in that well a lot of people buy
nfts because they believe in the artist
they want to support the artists
or they simply want to use it as an
investment strategy
like people do with trading cards you
know they have a specific trading card
and it can trade higher and higher and
higher
that's why you want to invest in really
really cool projects that you see
longevity in so it's all
kind of up to your own interpretation
and your back end
research or your just your interests in
general
if you want to just buy i don't know uh
the weekend's new nft of his music clip
and digital artwork behind it because
you just liked the weekend cool but then
surprise 10 years later it went up 10x
in value
even better and then you can trade it if
you want to if you're on to new artists
by then
i just see the value going up and up and
up and that's why i bought into crypto
punks
so simple obviously it's not a mona lisa
but the concept in my mind is
of that quality you can buy an nft
because it can go up in value similar to
trading cards you can also buy an nft
because you believe in the artist and
want to support the artist or you can
buy an nft
because you get some basic usage rights
of that digital graphic
or digital artwork but some people just
want the bragging rights of
owning the original verified copy
thanks to the ethereum blockchain or
thanks to blockchains
in general that's a way to prove that
you have
the real deal and you can just go up to
a party and be like look
i own that i don't know who does that i
don't even know who goes to parties
anymore
but the same thing can be said about
a mona lisa we have the original copy
at a museum but there's also actual
print copies
of the mona lisa as well but it's not
the real thing
and there's a difference in knowing that
you have the real thing or not even
though they look
so similar now i know with digital art
it is actually very it's
yes it is the same there's no
differences
and texture or anything like that but
what makes it different
is the technology behind it on the
blockchain of how it's being recorded
and the verification of that being the
original one you have the original
version of something
it's just like all your perspective in a
sense there is a strong
community behind nfts they have gotten
larger and larger
i'm a part of that community and i'm
learning
every day more and more about it i'm
sure there's a ton
i forgot to mention in this video i hope
i didn't forget
too much but i'm sure i did so there's a
lot to get into
but let's build a community here you
guys can comment below
all the things that i may have forgotten
all the things that
you want to mention and good tips or
information
that would be useful i'm going to
continue to post also comment below what
video you want to see next and i hope
this helps you
look into nfts a bit more and yeah who
knows
i'll be launching mine soon too i want
to launch something
that really brings up the value of my
nfts
for not only myself but for everybody
that's receiving the nft
as well or is the one purchasing the nft
and this is actually a point that i
should have mentioned
in the contracts of these nfts there can
be
points made of every transaction
the artist gets a benefit from the
future transactions and future sales of
an nft similar to the art world how
that's done with physical art
so ongoing they can generate income from
the growth
of their brand of their artwork and so
on
and this is so exciting because not only
is the artist incentivized to keep
growing their brand
keep growing their name keep providing
quality work
because that will bring up the value of
the nfts that they sold
and to whoever they sold it to and then
when they resell that item
that artist then benefits from
their growth of the value of that nft
so everybody's incentivized to just keep
growing
lots of levels to this lots of ways of
thinking about it
but i love adopting new ideas and like
i've said online like i said on my
twitter
i get really excited about this space
because it reminds me of the feeling i
had
during like the beginning of social
media
influencer times and how that felt then
and the new adoption and the people that
are having an open mind to
accept these new ideas and learnings of
these different communities and crypto
and blockchain technology we're here
we're talking about it we're learning
about it we're growing
it's growing hopefully it stays growing
that's the goal right
let me know what you want my next video
to be hopefully i didn't ramble too much
and i was to the point but now i'm
rambling i love you
goodbye give a thumbs up comment below
you know the algorithm help me out and i
hope you appreciate this video enough to
give me a thumbs up